vu que tu rappelles tout premier film je
me rappelle mon premier film j'avais 9
ans dans une mine neuf ans et je rêvais
de faire ce métier et je faisais plein
plein plein de casting et un jour on
m'appelle à la maison et c'était un truc
de dingue et on dit voilà vous est pris
pour deux jours dans ce film et j'ai une
scène dans le film mais pour moi ça a
été un symbole incroyable s'appelle
court toujours exactement quand même
toute ma famille me faisais des vannes
il me disait c'est ça qui va résumer sa
carrière chez nous camara vu tu
n'existes pas c'est les gens qui ont
voté
c'est logique ou bars
ils sont hyper début mon cas ça me
touche de voir ces images là tu vois pas
ce que je me rappelle de moi dix ans je
rêvais tellement de faire ce métier que
nous retrouver là sur un peu le truc
qu'on monte ça c'est drôle quand